[Music]
scott butterworth did a really good
interview with jet Jake Salomon the lead
on XCOM 2 and X calm over at Firaxis and
he in the aftermath of Mass Effect
Andromeda wanted to talk to him about
why some triple-a games are kind of like
doomed to fail before they're released
or why they are kind of a you know going
up against obstacles inherently Jake
Salomon I believe is that GDC was giving
a speech about why failure is important
in game development and how to learn
from it Scott wants to reach out about
that and use you know a mass effect as a
time peg then we all kind of want to
talk about that Triple A development is
kind of a you know an amorphous thing
it's hard to pin down and obviously with
publishers with developers there's a lot
of money involved and sometimes that is
inherently at war with the creative
pursuits of some developers and we also
kind of wanted to touch on how fan input
effects development and again if you
want to go read this whole interview
Scott Butterworth did a great job
talking to Jake Salomon and it's a great
line of questioning and its really
insightful if you want to know more
about a pretty prolific triple a
developer but yeah I don't know I kind
of wanted to this isn't really too
concrete or segment but I want to talk
to you guys about what you think you
know in the aftermath of Mass Effect
Andromeda I don't know it's it's
interesting to look at what failure even
means for Triple A game because
sometimes even if it doesn't have
critical reception still sells it can
sell really well Andromeda's sold yeah a
lot of copies and but you know critical
reception I think overall was kind of
disappointing I think you know people
are saying it's a fair game it's good a
lot of people really like it a lot of
people dislike it it's pretty polarizing
but I don't know Michael I don't know
what your take on kind of just in
general what does it even mean to you
know walk that tightrope between this
publishers aim of making money and the
developer trying to be you know have
creative pursuits yeah so there's one
aspect i was kind of throwing around in
my mind was the deadlines like the
depending pressure of a deadline has to
like get something done whether it's
good or not whether you as a creative
like artists whatever like it doesn't
really matter what you think of it you
have to make that deadline and so I
think that
when developers reach point where it's
like okay these things like we can ship
this product with these things missing
or with these like aspects rough and
we'll patch it out later as long as we
hit that deadline because it's not
self-imposed and when it's not
self-imposed you can't like it's harder
I imagine it's hard as like okay we need
like six more months before we push out
a like a finished product yeah because
you're like beholdin to the publisher
but the bigger problem though is that
you're beholden to money because
milestones are what these deadlines are
actually referred to and there are many
of them throughout development and if
you miss them you will not get it you
not get paid as much as a studio working
for a publisher in some cases so you can
actually miss your deadline but you just
won't make money back okay so it's it's
it's partially the pressure the
publisher is putting on the developer
but also the developers saying we need
this money to continue doing what we're
doing and pay everyone and do everything
that we expected to do on time it's a
weird mix of the two decks Andromeda had
development studio troubles kind of
throughout its five years of people that
have previously worked on Mass Effect
games or other by our projects left the
studio I know Mac Walters was there
throughout the whole thing and he was
there for release but a lot of people
looked at it and said this might've been
a case of EA just wanting to get this
game out right before the end of their
fiscal year yeah so they would have made
more money in that fiscal year yeah I
mean sometime no it's not just like a
like a one case scenario like I'm
describing like especially the
publishing date that's super-important
right but there are things that you have
to hit like during the course of
development that can if if they're not
given the time and attention they need
you know a year ahead of time that's
going to reflect in the end as well and
also another thing is that you know
post-release defining failure is that
you know like same thing with no man's
sky no man's guys sold incredibly well
but like what's the lasting impact of
releasing that game is that you know by
and large you leave a bad taste in
everyone's mouth and then so when like
when hello games wants to make another
game or when Bioware comes out with
their next project you know you have
this aftermath even though you sold your
game your previous game incredibly well
made a lot of money you know what's that
what's the effect on your future
projects like have you failed at that
point or are you more doomed to fail at
that point because of this reputation
from your previous game so I mean that's
kind of more nebulous I suppose but
that's one thing the thing about to
you as a consumer when I when a game
comes down like Oh what have they done
in the past what was their previous
project like should I be invested in
this yeah I mean that's a big
determinant of how excited I am for a
game if I don't know the like if it's a
new IP but I know this the developer I
know somebody who worked on like not
personally I mean but just I know their
work I'm like oh I really liked the way
they wrote this character I can't wait
to see what they do with this game and
the converse is true to where if you get
burnt by a developer you just probably
going to go into the next project a
little more skeptical of it keiji
inafune it comes to mind yeah one thing
Jake Salomon had said Scott asked him if
there's kind of a fear especially after
Mass Effect Andromeda because I was
Bioware Montreal's first title as a
collective studio of course there are
people there from earlier titles but if
there's a fear that your first failure
could also be your last and that might
be what determines your you know like
your career I had asked i believe it was
richard garriott who used to work at
looking last way back in the day and
then he did stuff at origin and now he's
at portal areum down in Austin he's also
like an astronaut and [ __ ] now because
of stuff eating back in 90 sees that he
essentially like established immersive
Sims with Warren Spector and Paul new
wrath but he was saying that you know
there's that mantra that developers is
only as good at their last game right
like kgm few night comes to mind too I
don't know I think the one you know we
remember recore remember money number
nine I think about that before I think
about like the good Megaman games now
and then Scott had been asking Jake if
that fear is there and Jacob and saying
yeah it's kind of throughout development
you're trying to learn from failure but
also trying to push away the fear that
it might sink you as a developer and but
then I want to look at more positive
games as well Kelly you had mentioned
doom get you mentioned breadth of a wild
for games that it seemed like you know
the development studio there's a lot of
trust places them and they kind of just
prioritize maybe different things then I
don't know this might be reductive than
EA might have with mass effect for
instance in terms of breath of a wild
how do you think that kind of isn't the
antithesis to the negative side of
triple-a development I think that kind
of boils down you know to a quote that
maybe Miyamoto has sort of you know
instilled in a lot of people in Nintendo
and he definitely as a lot of sway there
which it's along the lines of you know
Adelaide game is eventual
good a rush game is bad forever right so
like they understand that if they
publish something shitty that will sort
of be the legacy that is that you guys
are just talking about just now like
that will be the persistent legacy until
they can fix that somehow right but now
like with the great success like this
like they will be able to earn people's
favor much more easily down the road so
yeah delay this game a couple years to
make sure that you can keep people on
your good side mmhmm yeah Kelly then you
mentioned doom regs doom doom got
delayed for a while min doom key now
that was like one of the better games
last year best shooters in a while yeah
I mean I do most the originals one of
the first games ever played and the
thing about the new one was that it felt
like they respected the legacy of doom
but um didn't feel stuck on it like it
didn't feel like stuck in the past
either it was a newer take on something
that I loved when I was younger and I
just I thought they did a fantastic job
with it and I thought it's like a lot of
people were like oh the music is really
garish but I think it fits the spirit of
doom like that just like over the top
heavy metal like oh yeah are gonna kill
demons like I just adored that game so
much and I loved finding the like I
think the collectibles were really good
and the being able to find the 16-bit or
whatever levels you know kind of find
those little mini levels um I just I
loved so many things about that game and
I think it was better for the delay yeah
there's nothing interesting part of this
Jake Salomon interview in which he was
Scott asked him if you know when you see
games and early access all the time and
you know kick started and these people
are kind of you know like supposedly
have a say in development these fans
jquery sorry Scott was asking Jake you
know at a certain point is it more about
the fans what they want in a game in a
triple a game or is it more about what
the developers want to push out and then
Scott asked the question you know if it
becomes all about the fans is there the
danger of making it a poorly designed
game because fans might not have the
same knowledge as developers and might
not have the same probably definitely
don't have the same creative intent as
the developers and then you know p you
had mentioned like a lot of times over
the years when you interview developers
back in the day
or even like wrestling would literally
be to them who knows best about your
game you or the fans and Jake Salomon is
the first person that ever said the fans
and he continued to say something along
the lines of like I have no grounds to
get defensive about people criticizing
my design decisions because it's a game
i'm making for them and that to me is
just kind of insane because that draws a
line in the sand between making
something you're really passionate about
or making something that you think is
going to sell or just like please an
audience which this is a business that
is very important right but at the same
time there has to be an interesting
balance and he is just so far on the one
side of that that discussion is very
surprising to hear that yeah normally I
would say maybe that's just a PR
response no but he sounded very candid
yeah yeah no but he is throughout the
years he's always been kind of saying
that he said when they first started
because to reboot XCOM on 360 and then
you know with the enemy within it was a
huge it was a slog like there's things a
feature on polygon a while ago about
like just hit the stress it put on him
for like over 10 years between
pre-production and finally releasing it
and he was saying the entire time there
was also the fear the fans of the
original X comes back in the day the
isometric ones would be just hate him
right um and maybe that played a part in
his subsequent you know being beholden
to fans but they're certainly
responsible for him being able to do it
he continues to do right so why would he
want to screw that up like that that's
easy to sympathize with hmm but at the
same time like yeah I just I feel like
there has to be a better balance there
and I don't think that his work shows a
lack of that balance but has answered
yeah again it just made me I don't know
he didn't he didn't seem to like see
both sides yeah there's a bit of an
anomaly but you know like I think stuffs
worth talking about and as a great
interview should go read it between
Scott Butterworth and Jake Salomon it's
on gamespot it's called a ex-con
director on why some triple eight games
fail it's pretty insightful in terms of
a you know triple-a development
developing these huge budget games for
you know like you know these huge sales
but it's worth going to to read
especially in the wake of Mass Effect
Andromeda which a lot of people
criticize in terms of it's uh it's
released state it is improved now in
some aspects there's the patch that
released and it helped some of the
animations those I things technical
issues
stutters and whatnot so if you have been
holding off on Mass Effect Andromeda
maybe go check out some of our coverage
on that and see if it's worth going back
to in the meantime let us know you think
about this discussion we do the twitch
chat in the YouTube chat up right here
but also if you're watching this later
on on youtube or gamespot let us know
you think about triple-a development and
maybe what your takeaways are from that
Jake Salomon interview if you get the
chance to read it
[Music]